the uh new cd is called title the single
is sleep to dream
that song is pretty angry yeah i wonder
what you're saying what is that i love
that song but
you know what you're going to perform
for us in a few minutes yeah i
just i started writing it because uh my
first boyfriend was um
i was 14 and he was 18 and 18 year old
guys as we were saying before
jerks yeah so um and i was just like
really insecure and i couldn't defend
myself to him so i just kind of went
back and
did it on paper you wrote this at 14.
well i started writing it at 14 and that
was the thing that like
each other boyfriend that i had after
that kind of they all did the same thing
yeah
really so we're hearing really a slice
of your life
yes you want to do it now um yeah i was
thinking yeah rather than take a
commercial break let's just hear the
song because
it sounds really good the band is all
set up all right you do your thing
this is called sleep to dream i'll
listen to the lyrics
i tell you how i feel but you don't care
i said tell me the truth but you don't
dare
you say love is a hell you cannot bear
and i say give me my back and then go
there for all i care
i got my feet on the ground
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
i have never been so insulted all my
life
i could swallow the seeds right down off
this pie
first you are like a fool to be happy my
side and now you are like a fool that
you just want to hide and i can't abide
i got my feet on the ground and i don't
go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
don't you blame me okay don't bother to
explain
don't just show me your fake list of
crying shame
just go back to the rock from under
which you came
take a sorrow you gave them all the
stakes you cleared
don't forget to
[Music]
this man
[Music]
i got my feet
[Music]
this mama's body and this voice can
always
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
yeah wow that was really good